new delhi mégalopole de 19 millions
d'habitants
la moitié de la population canadienne
ces derniers jours la capitale indienne
est quasi déserte l'inde entière a été
placé en quarantaine il ya une semaine
depuis les millions de personnes ont
perdu leur emploi partout au pays et
n'ont plus aucun revenu pour eux le
risque d'attraper lakovic 19 n'est pas
la priorité immédiate
je préfère mourir du coronavirus que
mourir de faim en restant ici mon bébé
plat parce qu'il a faim je ne peux même
pas lui acheter du lait une autre
propriétaire nous a ordonné partir des
milliers d'entre eux retournent vers
leurs villages natals espérant y trouver
refuge et nourriture
mais les transports sont rares un
bungalow ma ville natale est à environ
500 kilomètres d'ici pied ce devrait
nous prendre une semaine pour y arriver
il n'y a aucun autobus aucun transport
je dois marcher porter mes deux enfants
et la route n'est pas seulement longue
et éreintante la répression policière et
l'intervention des autorités sanitaires
ces bleus les migrants se sont pris en
marché en gros ils peuvent être arrêtés
par la police et bats où c'est arrivé à
plusieurs reprises cet exode massif de
millions d'indiens fait craindre une
propagation du virus aux quatre coins du
pays
d'autant plus que les autorités
n'accorde que très peu de ressources à
la détection de la maladie
c'est moins 200 tests sont réalisés en
inde à chaque jour pour une population
d'1 point 3 milliards de personnes
dans le deuxième pays le plus peuplé du
monde les mesures pour combattre le
virus pourrait accentuer d'autres
menaces qui guettent la population à
savoir la famine et la propagation de
maladies
dans un contexte où le confinement et
pose une promiscuité qui pourrait faire
des milliers de victimes collatérales
ici julie et mon radio canada montréal